Oh my ears and whiskers,
my pocket watch has stopped.
Excuse me, sir,
do you have the time?
Please tell me that's
your pet rabbit.
That's Mr. W Rabbit
to you, ma'am.
There's a talking
rabbit that nobody
can see but us.
You're adorable.
Don't talk to me
like I-I-I-I-I like that.
I like that very much.
I ask why you're here.
It's a mystery.
I love mysteries!
My name is Alice.
This isn't Wonderland.
It's middle school.
Let's see. We started
seeing strange messages.
So we're dealing with a...?
Ghostwriter.
It's rolling out the
white carpet.
What is happening?
Donna told me.
You're solving
the mystery for a ghost
who's releasing
characters from books.
And you believed her?
She's a clone of Chevon.
They're identical.
Together we can do anything.
Look, I could give you a
whole speech about
how Asher's wrong.
Or, you could save us
the time and just trust me
because I get higher
grades than he does.
She did not just say that.
We went in to the book.
We became book characters?
Stylin'.
Excuse me, monster lady,
we come in peace.
We're your friends.
See, I got this.
I don't got this!
What is that?
I don't think these cowboys
are from the Old West.
What are you kids staring at?
Nothing.
Okay.
Night, night.
Is that the...?
The Mona Lisa.
Did that rat just
drive that car?
Prepare for a quantum time leap.
Dinosaurs!
I actually thought moving
here would be boring.
Who knew I'd be having
conversations
with a talking rabbit.
Time traveling with
a pirate and his pet rat.
And it all started in
this book store.
A clue from Ghostwriter.
I did not see the end coming.
I couldn't believe that—
Spoiler alert.
You sure have a
colorful imagination.
What are you doing?
We're practicing our miming.
You never know when
Cirque du Soleil will be hiring.